I don't really know why this is being
advertised as a comedy I mean it seems
pretty realistic to me as far as I know
this is actually a documentary of the
2000 election the campaign is directed
by Jay Roach and it stars Will Ferrell's
Zach Galifianakis Jason Sudeikis dan
Aykroyd John Lithgow and Dylan McDermott
now Will Ferrell as he generally is in
his movies is the best congressman ever
he always plays like the best ever of
whatever it is he's doing whether it's a
basketball player or a fashion model or
racecar driver he's always the best most
American of whatever it is that he is
attempting to do
he's been congressman for so long no one
ever actually runs against him he always
wins
until Zach Galifianakis says you know
why I'm gonna try and do that I'm gonna
run for Congress cuz it would be a lot
of fun yeah that's his voice in the
movie so for annoyed by that yeah that's
gonna be a problem so this movie really
is about the political bouts they go
through and how they fight with one
another and try to make each other
increasingly look even worse in the
public eye now I'm a fan of a lot of G
Roach's comedies I like the Austin
Powers movies Meet the Parents is
actually one of my favorite comedies
ever and going into this movie I didn't
really know what to expect cuz I missed
the screening of it it was on the same
night as the Bourne Legacy and I chose
that over this and so I went I saw it
Friday night I heard so many mediocre
things about it I liked Will Ferrell I
like Zach Galifianakis Galifianakis is
actually one of my favorite stand-up
comedians I think he is a masterful
comedian at improv especially and this
movie really didn't deliver for me at
all I laughed a few times in the movie a
few chuckles here and there
I like these stars they're good at what
they're doing but this just it wasn't
really that funny and I was so shocked
by that considering all the talent in
this movie and who actually sits down a
ghost guys Dan Aykroyd John Lithgow Zach
Galifianakis Jason Sudeikis
top it off with Will Ferrell step number
two we're gonna waste that talent and
people are gonna be wondering why it
wasn't really that funny I'm being a
little harsh here but you know when you
go into these movies you just have like
this giant slew of hilarious people you
really expect it to be hilarious and it
was just it was all right I'll tell you
who surprised me the most in this movie
and it's funny because he's actually the
one who is least known for comedy that's
Dylan McDermott he was actually really
funny in this movie and I think the fact
that he isn't as known for comedy
actually lent a lot to his performance
he plays this guy who just comes in and
slap Zach Galifianakis around he's
supposed to whip them up in his shape
and make him look like a model American
you know he definitely added some into
the film and I was surprised by his
performance it's so cool to see dan
Aykroyd in a movie but it's like what
the heck dude you're funny you are a
funny guy let's be funny but he wasn't
funny
there are good things about this movie
these are talented actors and when the
jokes hit they hit and there was
definitely some funny scenes in this
movie a lot of people have said this
already in their reviews but I agree the
dinner-table scene I thought was very
funny I liked Galifianakis more in this
movie than Will Ferrell I thought he was
funnier he had a comedic sense even
about his composure I just felt like
Will Ferrell was phoning a lot of this
movie in and I liked him a lot and I
think he's very funny but this just kind
of came off as is typical I'm the big
American here and I'm gonna do
everything better I'm gonna get all the
chicks I want I'm gonna do all this and
everything it's just like it was just
the same I like the guy but at this
point I would like to see something
different
my biggest problem at this movie though
it seems like they tried to mask poor
jokes or something that just wasn't
funny by just throwing in a cuss word I
think that people use swearing in movies
a lot of times especially in comedies to
cover over the fact that they can't
think of what to say and it just wasn't
funny after a while and I could tell
even the audience laughter was dying
down with each consecutive use of a
swear word and it was just like it's not
funny anymore it's just really not that
funny which is shocking considering the
talent involved I'm gonna give the
campaign a c-minus I wouldn't really
suggest seeing it if you're a hardcore
fan of Zach Galifianakis I would though
because he is very funny in this movie I
think it's just that Will Ferrel really
didn't add much to this movie and I was
really surprised so out of the three
movies that are coming out this weekend
Bourne Legacy hope Springs and this I
liked Hope Springs the most that you
know I mean it's the one that more than
likely you aren't going to see but I
would suggest seeing it if you want to
see a movie that is actually very
sweetly funny with some good comic
timing and great performances and a good
script as well and as always guys if you
like this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuck my eyes